I love jeopardy but I'm starting to
think Alex Trebek has been hosting that
show way too long I'm serious
recently I'm starting to think he's I
think he's losing it take a look
business is good for 600 young Starbucks
ads a shoe polish blood and phlegm ma to
make insect infested cupcakes called pig
stomach because it's environmentally
friendly he told us he ste two other
words 1200 Tom Hanks recently used
cocaine to get the shampoo out of the
severed head of this newborn child oh my
god I'm totally wired what is bold face
recess pondered joy to the world
kangaroos and gorillas of German Jewish
descent snowmobile across pickled sushi
for 36 hours to get to this champagne
and dirt island Simple Simon met a
pieman going on up there
physic before please David Hasselhoff
traded his half of this German sausage
for a band of hair shaped alcoholic
women which is weird because he's One
himself
johner terry and that greek philosopher
was Aristotle
for 800 please bum rule mill Gibson gets
slightly wet while working on Gary
Busey's push down the rabbit hole
they are stands for reentry
[Applause]
again I only got one of those